i love paper and and i love technology
and what i do is is i make paper
interactive and that's what i say when
people ask me what i do but it really
confuses most people so really the best
way for me to convey it
is to take the technology and be
creative and create experiences
so i tried to think what i could use for
here and a couple of weeks ago i had a
crazy idea that i wanted to
print
two dj decks and to try and mix some
music and i'm going to try and show that
at the end and um the suspense will be
as much mine if it works
and i'm not a dj and i'm not a musician
so i'm a little bit scared of that
um
so
i think i found the best way to describe
my journey is just to mention a few
little things that have happened to me
throughout my life there's three
particular things that i've done and
i'll just describe those first and then
talk about some of my work
so when i was a kid i was obsessed with
wires and
i used to thread them under my carpet
and thread them behind the walls and
have little switches and little speakers
and i wanted to make my bedroom be
interactive but kind of all hidden away
and i was also um really interested in
in wireless as well so i bought one of
those little kits that you could get to
make a radio transmitter and i got an
old book and i carved out the inside and
i hid it inside there and then i placed
it next to my dad and snuck back to my
bed but back to my bedroom and tuned in
in the raid on the radio so i could
eavesdrop
i was not at all interested in what he
was saying it's more that i just liked
the idea of an everyday object
sort of having something inside and
doing something different
um
several years later i managed to
successfully fail all of my exams and
didn't really leave school with um with
much much to show for at all and
my parents
maybe as a reward
brought me what turned out to be a
one-way ticket to australia and i came
back home about four years later
i ended up on a farm
in the middle of nowhere it was in far
western new south wales and this farm
was 120 000 acres there was 22 000 sheep
and it was about 40 degrees or 100 or so
fahrenheit
and on this farm there was a farmer his
wife and
there was the four-year-old daughter
and they kind of took me
into the farm and showed me what it was
like to live and work
obviously one of the most important
things was the sheep and so my job was
well pretty much to do everything but it
was about
bringing the sheep back to the homestead
and we'd do that by building fences
using motorbikes and horses and the
sheep would make their way all the way
back to the shearing shed for the
different seasons
and what i learned was although at the
time like everyone else i thought sheep
were pretty stupid because they didn't
do what we wanted them to do what i
realized now probably only just in the
last few weeks looking back is the sheep
weren't stupid at all we'd put them in
an environment where they didn't want to
be and they didn't want to do what we
wanted them to do
so the challenge was to try and get them
to do what we wanted to do by by
listening to the weather the lay of the
land and and creating things that would
let the sheep flow and go where we
wanted them to go another bunch of years
later i ended up at cambridge university
at the cavendish laboratory in the uk
doing a phd in physics
and my phd was to move electrons around
one at a time
and i realized again it's kind of these
realizations looking back as you know to
what i did i realized now that it was
pretty much the same as as moving sheep
around
it really is it's just you do it by
changing an environment and it's it's
that's kind of been a big lesson to me
that you can't act on any object you
change its environment and the object
will flow so
we made it very small so things were
about 30 nanometers in size making it
very cold so
at liquid helium temperatures
and change environment by changing the
voltage and the electrons could make
flow around a loop one at a time on and
off a little memory node and i wanted to
go one step further and i wanted to move
one electron on and one electron off and
i was told that i wouldn't be able to do
this which you know as we've heard from
other people that's the thing that makes
you do it and i was determined and i
managed to show that i could do that and
a lot of that learning i think came from
being on that farm because when i was
working on the farm
we'd have to use what was around us we'd
have to use the environment and there
was no such thing as something can't be
done because you're in an environment
where if you can't do what you need to
do
you can die and you know i had seen that
sort of thing um happen
so now my obsession is printing and i'm
really fascinated by the idea of using
conventional printing processes so the
types of print that's used to create
many of the things around us to make
paper and card interactive
when i spoke to some printers when i
started doing this and told them what i
wanted to do which was to print
conductive inks onto paper and they told
me it couldn't be done again the kind of
favorite thing um so
i
i got about 10 credit cards and loans
and got myself into a very close to kind
of bankruptcy really and bought myself
this huge printing press which i had no
idea how to use at all it's about five
meters long and i covered myself and the
floor with ink and made a massive mess
but i learned to print and then i took
back to the printers and showed them
what i've done and they were like of
course you can do that why didn't you
come here in the first place
that's always the case
so
what we do is we take conventional
printing presses we make conductive inks
and run those through a press and
basically just letting hundreds of
thousands of electrons flow through
pieces of paper so we can make that
paper interactive and it's pretty simple
really it's just a collection of of
things that have been done before but
bringing them together in a different
way so we have a piece of paper with
conductive ink on
and then add on to that a small circuit
board with a couple of chips one to run
some capacitive touch software so we
know where we've touched it and the
other to run
quite often some wireless software so
the piece of paper can can connect
so i'll just describe a couple of things
that um that we've created there's lots
of different things we've created this
is one of them because i love cake and
this one is it's a large poster and you
touch it and has a little speaker behind
it and the poster talks to you when you
touch it and asks you a series of
questions and it works out your perfect
cake but it doesn't tell you the cake
there and then it uploads a picture and
the reason why it shows that cake for
you to our facebook page um and and to
twitter so we're trying to create that
connection between the physical and the
digital but have it not looking on a
screen and just looking like a regular
poster
we've worked with um a bunch of
universities on on a project looking at
interactive newsprint so for example
we've created a newspaper regular
newspaper you can wear a pair of
headphones that are connected to it
wirelessly and when you touch it you can
hear the music that's described on the
top which is something you can't read
you can hear
a press conference as well as reading
what the editor has determined that
press conference was about and you can
press a facebook book like button or you
can vote on something as well
something else that we created this was
an idea that i had a couple of years ago
and so we've done a project on this was
for funding from the government for
user-centred design for energy efficient
buildings difficult to say and something
i had no idea what it was when i went
into the workshop but i quickly learned
um and we wanted to try and encourage
people to to use energy better and i
really liked the idea that instead of
looking at dials and and you know and
reading things to say
you know looking at your energy usage i
wanted to create a poster that was
wirelessly connected and had color
changing inks on it and so if your
energy use
was trending better then the leaves
would appear and the rabbits would
appear and all would be good and if it
wasn't then the graffiti and the leaves
would fall off the trees so it's trying
to make you look after something in your
immediate environment which you don't
want to see not you know not looking so
good rather than expecting people to do
things in the local environment because
of the effect that it has a long way off
and i think kind of like going back to
the farm it's about how to let people do
what you want them to do rather than
making people do what you want them to
do
okay
this is the thing i'm really scared of
so um a couple of things i've created
are there's a poster over here that's um
you can play drums on um and i am not a
musician it seemed like a good idea at
the time
if anyone wants to try and play drums
then they can i'll just describe how
this works this poster is wirelessly
connected to my um cell phone and when
you touch it it connects to the app
[Music]
and it has really good response time
it's using bluetooth 4 so it's pretty
instantaneous
okay
thanks
um and there's a couple of other things
so um
this one is like a sound board so you
can touch it
and i just love these horrible noises
[Music]
okay
and this is the dayton table so it's
wirelessly linked to my ipad and this is
the software that's running on the ipad
um
oh yes i just love doing that
[Laughter]
i'm not a dj though but i just always
wanted to do that
so i have a crossfader
and i have the two days
so i've made some new technology and i
love things being creative and i love
working with creative people so um my 15
year old niece she's amazing she's
called charla and i asked her to record
something and i worked with a friend
called elliot to put some beats together
so this is my niece charlotte
[Music]
oh
yes
so that's pretty much what i do i just
love bringing technology together having
a lot of fun being creative but it's not
about the technology it's just about i
want to create some great experiences so
thank you very much
you